MARIA: WELCOME BACK, PRESIDENT
TRUMP SIGNED $8.3 BILLION
PACKAGE TO FIGHT AND TREAT
CORONAVIRUS.
THE BILL PASSED CONGRESS BE
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
WITH ONLY 3GOP LAWMAKERS VOTING
AGAINST IT.
JOINING ME HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN MCCARTHY, REPUBLICAN FROM
CALIFORNIA.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, SIR.
3 REPUBLICANS VOTING AGAINST IT.
I DON’T GET THAT AT ALL IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE CRISIS.
NO, YOU HAVE TO ASK THEM.
WE SHOULD HAVE HAD THE BILL A
WEEK EARLIER.
THE DEMOCRATS HELD THE BILL SO
CONGRESSMAN BUSTOS SHOULD RUN
ADS AGAINST REPUBLICANS.
AS YOU SAID THIS IS VERY SERIOUS
AND WE SHOULD TAKE IT FOR THE
SERIOUSNESS THAT IT SHOULD BE.
$8.3 BILLION, DOES 3 MAIN
THINGS, TESTING, TREATMENT AND
TELEHEALTH WHICH IS VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WHAT YOU WANT
TO DO IS MAKE SURE YOU HAVE
CONTAINMENT BUT MAKE SURE THE
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO GET THE
TREATMENT THEY NEED.
WE WERE ABLE TO MAKE A REVISION
IN THAT WHERE PEOPLE USE
TECHNOLOGY TODAY TO BE ABLE TO
TALK TO A DOCTOR NOT GOING OUT
AND AFFECTING EVERYBODY ELSE
AROUND THEM AND MAKE A REAL
DIFFERENCE.
MARIA: ARE YOU GOING TO BE ABLE
TO CLEAR THE DECKS IN TERMS OF A
VACCINE?
I MEAN, THE BUREAUCRATIC PROCESS
IN TERMS OF GETTING DRUGS PASSED
THROUGH THE FDA, ANYTHING THAT
YOU CAN DO DIFFERENTLY TO HURRY
AND GET A VACCINE SOONER THAN
LATER?
I KNOW THERE ARE THERAPIES THAT
WE ARE WAITING ON AS WELL FOR A
COUPLE OF MONTHS.
>> REMEMBER, THEY WERE WITH THE
PRESIDENT THIS WEEK AS WELL WHEN
HE WENT TO NIH AND CDC.
YOU HAVE GILLIAD IN TRIALS IN
CHINA AND AMERICA.
YOU HAVE JOHNSON & JOHNSON
WORKING ON A VACCINE.
THE REAL CHALLENGE IS CHINA WAS
NOT FORTHCOMING AND NOT ALLOWING
DOCTORS IN WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP
WAS REQUESTING EARLY ON IN
DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR.
THAT’S WHY WE WEREN’T GETTING
ALL THE INFORMATION.
NOW THAT WE HAVE IT, WE KNOW
EVERY SINGLE DAY WE ARE LEARNING
SOMETHING MORE ABOUT THIS AND
AMERICA WILL SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
NOT JUST FOR AMERICA BUT FOR THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
MARIA: WHAT DOES THIS MEAN FOR
XI JINPING.
FIRST HE HAD PROTESTORS AND NOW
THIS AND SWINE FLU.
DICTATOR FOR LIFE AND HAS LOTS
OF PLANS FOR 2030, IS THIS
ENOUGH TO KNOCK HIM OFF HIS
PERCH?
>> I DON’T KNOW IF IT’S ENOUGH
TO KNOCK HIM OFF HIS PERCH?
TO DENY DOCTORS TO BE IN THERE
IS AFFECTING THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
THE OTHER THING, HIS OWN
ECONOMY, I KNOW IT’S CLOSED
ECONOMY BUT THERE ARE MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE OUT OF WORK BEING TOLD
TO STAY HOME AND NOW EVERY
COUNTRY WILL LOOK AT THEIR
SUPPLY CHAIN AND WE AS AMERICA
AS PRESIDENT TRUMP ASKED US TO
DO BEFORE.
OUR KEY INGREDIENTS ARE
MINERALS.
THEY WEREN’T OPEN ABOUT IT WHERE
WE COULD HAVE CONTAINED THIS
INSIDE CHINA.
MARIA: LET’S MOVE TO THE ECONOMY
HERE AND 2020 ELECTION.
YOU’RE TRYING TO TAKE BACK THE
HOUSE, THE GOP.
GREAT NUMBERS ON JOBS IN
FEBRUARY, 273,000 JOBS CREATED
IN THE MONTH OF FEBRUARY.
YOU STILL SEE ECONOMY THAT IS
STRONG AND EXPECTATION THAT IS
THINGS WILL SLOW DOWN IN A BIG
WAY.
ARE YOU GOING TO COME UP WITH A
ANOTHER STIMULUS PACKAGE, TAX
CUT PLAN, HOW ARE YOU GOING TO
DEAL WITH AN ECONOMY THAT IS
SURE TO SLOW IN TERMS OF
MANUFACTURING IN CHINA?
>> REMEMBER WHERE WE ARE
STARTING FROM, THE STRONGEST
ECONOMY IN 20 YEARS THANKS TO
THE REPUBLICANS AND
ADMINISTRATION TO DO ON TAX
REFORM.
WE ARE LOOKING AT THINGS
SURGICALLY, AREAS AND INDUSTRIES
THAT MAY NEED HELP.
THAT MAY BE A SITUATION WHERE
YOU RELIEVE SOME REGULATIONS OR
TAX BUT IT’S SOMETHING THAT WE
ARE STUDYING NOW BECAUSE YOU ARE
CORRECT, MARIA, COMING OFF
270,000 JOBS WHEN WE THOUGHT
THERE WAS A HUNDRED THOUSAND.
YOU LOOK ANYWHERE IN THE ELSE,
THEY ARE JEALOUS OF WHAT AMERICA
HAS BEEN ABLE TO CREATE AND WE
WANT TO MAINTAIN IT.
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE IS
THAT DEMOCRATS ARE IN POWER.
WILL THEY DO SOMETHING TO HELP
THE ECONOMY GROW OR ARE THEY
CARING MORE ABOUT POLITICS TO
TRY TO HARM THE PRESIDENT?
AND WE’VE WATCHED TIME AND TIME
AGAIN THEY ALWAYS PICK POLITICS.
IF YOU WANT TO CHANGE THE HOUSE
YOU HAVE TO GO TO
TAKETHEHOUSE.COM TO MAKE A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE HERE.
YOU SHOULD PEOPLE BEFORE
POLITICS.
MARIA: YOU HEARD GOVERNOR CUOMO,
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS AFRIDAY OF
JOE BIDEN, BOTTOM LINE, YOU
CALLED IT ON THIS PROGRAM.
YOU SAID THAT THE DEMOCRATS ARE
CLEARING THE DECKS FOR BIDEN AND
THEY ARE COLLUDING AGAINST
BERNIE AGAIN, THEY ARE ALL
GETTING BEHIND JOE BIDEN RIGHT
NOW.
WHAT ARE YOUR PROSPECTS GOING
INTO 2020 ELECTION.
REMEMBER WHAT THEY DID TO BERNIE
SANDERS 4 YEARS AGO.
THE CHAIR HAD TO RESIGN BECAUSE
THEY FOUND OUT THEY WERE
CHEATING.
NANCY PELOSI, THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE, HELD IMPEACHMENT NOT TO
GO TO THE SENATE BECAUSE
SENATORS COULDN’T CAMPAIGN ANDIA
GOT KLOBUCHAR TO BACK OUT AND
BUTTIGIEG TO ENDORSE BEFOREHAND.
ONE THING LOOKING BACK AS A
REPUBLICAN, NOMINATING JOE BIDEN
IS THE SAME THINGS AS
REPUBLICANS NOMINATE MITT
ROMNEY.
IT MAY MAKE THE ESTABLISHMENT
LOOK GOOD BUT HE’S NOT WINNING.
MARIA: MITT ROMNEY WILL BE THE
VOTE THAT GOES AGAINST PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
HE’S MADE THAT CLEAR.
>> YEAH, BUT THIS SHOULD NOT BE
ABOUT POLITICS.
ANY ELECTED OFFICE THAT USES
THEIR OFFICE OR HAVE CHILDREN
WHO USES THEIR OFFICE TO GET
ECONOMIC GAIN WHERE YOU’RE
GETTING $50,000 A MONTH.
HOW MANY AMERICANS DON’T MAKE
THAT IN A YEAR, AND YOU HAVE NO
EXPERIENCE WHATSOEVER AND THE
ONLY REASON THAT YOU HAVE THAT
JOB BECAUSE OF YOUR FATHER AND
YOUR FATHER WITHHOLDS MONEY TO A
COUNTRY TO CHANGE THE
INVESTIGATION OF THE PEOPLE THIS
HIRED YOU, THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD
BE THE FIRST PERSON
INVESTIGATING THIS.
ALL THEY’VE DONE WITH THEIR
MAJORITY IS INVESTIGATE, BUT THE
ONLY PLACE THEY WOULDN’T
INVESTIGATE IS JOE BIDEN BECAUSE
THEY CARE ABOUT POLITICS INSTEAD
OF THE RULE OF LAW.
MARIA: WE HAVE BEEN WAITING ON
LINDSEY GRAHAM TO CALL SOMEBODY
DOWN TO SUBPOENA HUNTER BIDEN,
SUBPOENA SOMEBODY AROUND THIS,
IS THIS GOING TO BE INVESTIGATED
OR NOT?
>> YOU HAVE SENATOR JOHNSON
ASKING FOR A SUBPOENA AND
RIGHTFULLY SO, AND THIS
SHOULDN’T BE ABOUT POLITICS.
IT SHOULD BE ABOUT THE RULE OF
LAW AND I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
DEMOCRATS CARE ABOUT THIS TOO
AND VOTE FOR THIS AS WELL.
MARIA: CONGRESSMAN, BEFORE YOU
GO, ANY REACTION TO WHAT SENATOR
SCHUMER SAID TRYING TO ATTACK A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE AND IN
EXPLAINING IT, HEY, I’M FROM
BROOKLYN.
I’M FROM BROOKLYN.
I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT.
IS HE SAYING THAT PEOPLE FROM
BROOKLYN THREATEN SUPREME COURT
JUSTICES?
>> HE’S SAYING MORE THAN THAT.
HE’S THE LEADER OF THE SENATE,
HE’S THE LEADER OF THE
DEMOCRATS, HE’S STANDING BEFORE
THE SUPREME COURT TRYING TO
INFLUENCE THE OUTCOME.
IN AMERICA WE ENCOURAGE THE
EXCHANGE OF IDEAS, NOT TO THE
IDEA THAT YOU’RE GOING TO
INTIMIDATE.
REMEMBER, THEY DISLIKED
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR WINNING,
THEY IMPEACHED.
THEY SEEK COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND
GO AFTER THEM TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE THEM.
WE WATCHED WHAT SENATOR SCHUMER
WAS DOING, THE INTIMIDATION
THERE, IF I WAS A DEMOCRAT IN
THE SENATE, I WOULD HAVE CHANGED
MY LEADERSHIP IF THIS WAS WHAT
WAS HAPPENING.
MARIA: AND I WOULD KEEP BROOKLYN